fraîcheur et on va cueillir les
chroniqueurs qui sont tous déguisés
alors il ya des bons et de moins bons
déguisement à vous de décider bien sûr
qui a le meilleur déguisement attention
c'est parti
voici le premier je ne sais pas qui va
arriver je découvre comme vous c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
tu crées dans les nouveaux normalement
il est en part à mon frère on dirait le
gars qui étaient là puis d'être laurent
sabau attend les années en bacs verts à
faire aller faire des pipes en bas donc
après à mon avis va voir valérie benaïm
si je suis valérie bénaïm c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai compris
ces comprimés des grisons géraldine
maillet g complet mais la libye là c'est
génial alors est ce que vous savez quand
qui suis-je en cocotte
ouais et dont cléopâtre alma le sol et
que le patou savait qu'elle était
ambitieuse oui séductrice rue belle
intelligente manipulatrice et elle avait
un rêve c'est quoi participer à pyramide
non point la tristesse alors d'accord on
accueille le prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors attendez bonne et là je vous ai
temps rihanna joseph îles marquises des
gants cours c'est quoi ton mari en
toilettes mariens wallet marie
antoinette bah bravo c'est très réussi
et dieu bénisse avec les chaussures qui
sont pas tout le monde et vous êtes venu
vous êtes venus comme en vrai nom
voiture en voiture avec un truc plus
gros qu'une voiture s'est amusé non
c'est quoi être plus gros qu'une voiture
à vannes non plus gros a bu ce nom en
avion non une navette non plus gros
qu'une voiture il ya quoi une usine plus
petite qu'une camionnette fait qu'une
camionnette
je passe mes étés conquois le titre
qu'une gamine gros qu'une camionnette a
plus rien qu'à nous pouet pouet
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas de disney bonifiée est long
mais qu'elle abat mais je suis surtout
aulas d'or mais j'ai pas possible allez
prochain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai salon vous êtes en bratisla boys
il
vous êtes en britney j'adore l'école et
les sushis alors chiant en écolières
sushiman hu
[Musique]
pour l'instant vous êtes formidables et
4 mois je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
vous voter pour le meilleur déguisement
http mp déguisements tout simplement
acheter même pu partir à ces partis le
prochain cycle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est beau ça pour défendre fatou c'est
quelqu'un la taxe de séjour vous allez
défendre
vous êtes en quoi alors en gladiateur
mais importateurs caf un régime j'adore
messaouda hyper merci merci non je
déconne et merci il m'a fait pire
franchement non mais franchement j'adore
monde et je croyais que je croyais que
c'était le gars de pertes on coule c'est
bien jean salençon bon mari
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la foule jacquouille il ait afouda
exceptionnelle renchérit d'amour se fait
remarquer c'est une émission il ya 50
ans billy et c'est le cas dans les dix
alors vous êtes vous êtes belle en
toutes circonstances je voulais non non
vous n'êtes pas et je le dis on je ne
suis pas le seul à le dire je ne suis
pas le savez il ya plein de gens vivants
et morts qu'ils allaient pousser le
bouchon et bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi qu'est ce qu'il a dit sors ton art
ou ton sexe waseda c'est là que vous
avez vraiment une épée beaucoup plus
grand que l'autre tu as raison tu aimes
tant d'autres non merci
six excès les lourdes alors fait gaffe
tu peux attention c'est lourd et dur
fais gaffe tu pètes blessés oui c'est
vraiment c'est comment tu prends ça tu
en as déjà fait tu sais comment te poses
as tu vois tu prends ça comme ça mais
nous regardent comme si lui fait rien
faire elle même ton geste l'année garde
ça devient près de toile verte devant
toi regardez-la revers devant toi
regarde la cible oui elle est là t'as
jamais oh qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
que c'est que cet ep chez citi j'ai
senti un petit matou nous prenons un
opinel non je ne crois pas je sentais un
couteau suisse dans le dos pour filmer
la musique de cul quand j'arrive en
prédateur ça vous va hyper bien vraiment
il ya plein de gens qui me disaient
barça et le casque ce qui lui va bien
[Applaudissements]
moi regarder emma heming casquette de
commandement ils m'ont mis la casquette
zae le gars le préfet là bas
tu as également epr est également arrivé
c'est une meilleure prime aujourd'hui
ah non pas du tout je te vois aller
saluer les filets avant tu te fous de ça
dans l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est alice au pays des
boulettes cloche beinheim la c1 c'est
vraiment c'est un conseil que je vous
donne à y mettre et celle ci tente comme
ça mais benhaim estomac toi demain tapas
l'émission tapas tpm pays non tu pars en
couleurs mais gênant mais non mais non
sera juste et mieux non mais je ne dis
rien à voir non mais c'est ce qui est
bon que tu passes mais t'es malade avec
les sourciers comme ça mais bienvenu
cette année j'ai subi le même tracé sont
blancs comme vous je dois tout petit
zizi les gros c'est ça qui marche on
dira bilboquet l'envers
[Applaudissements]
très bien cet abonnement mais non
benhaim je vous jure la question
téléspectateurs oui moi j'adore la javel
était blond non mais sur un corner alors
si mais pas de banc mais non je suis est
magnifique oui non mais je te le dis
allez poser les bonnes questions est
belle mais je te le dis pose-toi les
bonnes questions beinheim oui tu te le
jure fais moi plaisir vient on le fait
viande
[Applaudissements]
il répond autodata
challans au père jean elle est sublime
devra commencer par des mèches on
emploie avec fois les tubes assad a aimé
on sépare d'éclaircir que magnifique
tout d'un coup c'est un combat il faut
que tu fasses un truc aussi d'un
potentiel élevé à vallière à potentiel
énorme un balayage non mais franchement
voilà non mais je te le dis bah tu vas
non bah non pas vous laisser entendre
qu'elle était moche avant bras du tout
elle avait très unie rooney qui avait
été fait ne suis pas beaucoup leurs
enseignants membres déchirés elle va
faire quoi d'affaires qui dit du tout je
veux dire en couleur blond hollywoodien
et jennifer aniston y aller franchement
tu fasses un blond hollywood est à dire
un blond avec tony g de d'andorre
j'adore aller on a là d'autres le mac
est basé à pékin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nature pas un hasard je ne peux plus de
julie raynaud la productrice dans
l'oreillette sur décoller on dirait que
je vais faire décoller un avion
je ne sais pas quand même pas la frêle
nous la chine apporte quoi